mr depp mentions aquaman doesn't he yes
he does sir i got you that role in
aquaman didn't he
excuse me mr depp
got you that role in aquaman didn't he
no miss vasquez i got myself that role
by auditioning
12 million instagram followers
how long did it take you to apologize to
each one of them for bumblebee
i walked out of that movie
i'm just kidding i didn't walk out of
the movie
i skipped out because i was so happy to
be leaving justin as a father of six you
got to straighten up son
you know last year you were ranked the
fifth most hated person of all time
kim jong-un didn't even score that low
and he uses your music to [ __ ]
torture people
next to him is a woman who's passed for
white for years
and used to be a [ __ ] in detroit
look at all these beautiful people here
to pay tribute to you the senator rich
little paul lind on the end paul if you
want to order do it now the kitchen's
going to close
sorry about your seat paul why don't you
get a pillow so you can see us
uh all the baristas are buffed shirtless
guys i can't wait to check it out said
the health inspector
said colin please don't tell scarlet you
saw me here
german researchers have recorded the
shortest interval of time for an event
to begin and end the event finished so
quickly scientists have named it che
when you're in the recording studio do
you ever think um hey what if i don't
make something shitty does that ever
does that pop into your mind in the in
the
process
uh you don't really need to wear green
on st patrick's day because you look
like uh like some sort of crazy monster
leprechaun that lives underneath a
bridge yeah well thank you for that
you're welcome
next sitting to him is a big black
gorilla
[Applause]
my kid sammy you're a black man i took a
guess
if you ain't black you fell into a
bucket of m m's
cardi b zacky g jerry j
what's the j
jew
i don't get offended by being all the
wrong name i do you do yeah who do they
mistake you for i went to a correct no i
went to work
that was that was really good
that was really good man
let's talk about uh
where do you where do you keep your
oscar your oscars trophy
i mean your uh
blockbuster entertainment award
where do you keep that remember the
words of a great negro i say that
honestly all peoples are alike we are
all working you live in my neighborhood
i live in yours right sam are you crazy
[Music]
always
i received the script police from hong
kong police from china cia from hong
kong cia from china
can i have some like uh some of the
music
la la land uh
like like meet the parents
now those kind of movies no
[Applause]
the action comedy china hong kong china
home hey yeah
the same thing happened to me i
i actually the black dude go get steve
[Music]
i'm sorry i i don't
i'm serious i don't understand the word
from your mouth
[Applause]
jackie can i tell you something yeah i
ain't understood a damn thing you said
either
[Applause]
i don't know what you're talking about
i'm just telling
he got to repair he ain't got to repair
nothing you got to stop babying your
players you got baby that's why you
ain't win he got the i didn't have duane
i didn't have dwyane wade and copyright
carried me up and down the court so why
you know what because i got three finals
in between chuck because
i mean you are a great player
[Music]
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entire
entire seven million dollars
settlement to charity at that point had
you that's incorrect
sitting here today ms heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of this settlement seven million to
charity and i intend to fulfill those
obligations
that's not my question
please try to answer my question
sitting here today
you have not donated the seven million
dollars donated now pledged donated the
seven million dollars divorce settlement
to charity
i use pledge and donation
synonymous with one another
miss heard
i don't use it synonymously that's how
donations are paid misheard respectfully
that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the aclu yes or no
i have not yet
and as of today you have not paid 3.5
million dollars of your own money to the
children's hospital los angeles correct
i have not yet johnny sued me so as of
today
you have not donated
paid
seven million dollars of your divorce
settlement to charity right
i have not been able to fulfill those
those uh obligations yet
and that's because you did want
something
didn't you i didn't want anything and i
didn't get anything you wanted mr duff's
money i have nothing against china i
just hate that their leaders are so much
smarter than our leaders 2016 we will
not be the world leader anymore we have
been always but in 2016 china becomes
the great economic leader even if mitt
romney is elected he said maybe you can
turn it around do you think he could
turn it around i think we can do you
think mitt romney could i think i think
he can
as a line of clothing now where were
these made these were made i don't know
where they were made but they were made
someplace but they're great it's ties
shirts cufflinks everything sold at
macy's and they're doing great number
one selling tie anywhere in the world
number one cylinder anywhere in the
world
you wouldn't wear this we also have them
in white and beautiful where are the
shirts made
bangladesh well it's good okay we employ
people in bangladesh high is where the
thais
are beautiful they are great the ties
are made in where china ties are made in
china
[Applause]